[Music]
hey everybody
it's wednesday and look it's right there
she did like a really cute thing this
morning she's not a real i mean she's
very affectionate she likes to like lay
down next to you and stuff like that
but this morning she came in here and
she was like farting around on my desk
like she usually does like snuffling
around and
you know licking it and whatever and she
climbed down and like curled up in my
lap
i don't think she's ever done that in
the whole time that we've had her yeah
beijing is more of a lap kitty she's
coming over here now yeah she was like
i'm gonna tear that [ __ ] up
all right so um see how everybody's
doing see who's in the
chat oracle says jenny doesn't pookie do
something cute every morning
she does she's always doing something
cute even just sitting there and looking
she's doing something cute yeah okay
yeah everybody's here yeah all right all
the regular people are here
um yeah so looks like soph's in there
yeah i saw her earlier it's all it's
gone off my tammy
fourth drawer okay everybody says all
hail pookie we shouldn't
have a shirt that says that too yeah she
needs a little she needs her own little
shirt
i was looking for a cartoon that looked
like her the other day but like i said
none of them were cute enough
i'd imagine everybody had a stressful
[ __ ] night last night waiting for the
[ __ ] results of this [ __ ] but they
told us from
day one months back that oh it's going
to take weeks to sort this out it's
going to be a contested election and
of course that's that's what they had
planned well no this is how long it
always takes when it's close
it doesn't take 10 it doesn't take this
long they'll know by the end of the week
i told you yesterday i said they're not
going to know by the end of the night
yeah you believe what you want to
believe last time we knew you had a
clear count
it i don't want to argue i don't want to
argue about it from
y'all on camera it's it wasn't close
they made it close
yeah you're gonna see all right whatever
you're gonna see
whatever so uh yeah the one where this
is what we're talking about today we
actually watched this
last week but we didn't get around to um
to talking about it
i can't remember who it was that uh
recommended this
but this is on netflix and it's a
russian
series called to the lake i guess the
russian title is
epidemia or whatever it's maybe like
epidemic or whatever
um so it's weird because if you look at
the trailer it's almost kind of like
seems like a zombie series but it's not
exactly like that
it's kind of more i think it's eight
episodes as the first
first season and hopefully there'll be a
second one because they left it on a
huge cliffhanger which i'm not gonna say
what it is but um basically what this is
and it's weird because it premiered in
russia last year
like before the pandemic hit so it's
very um
spooky like the way it kind of like
predicted like some [ __ ]
i guess not because people have been
talking about flus and stuff going
around for like years and years ever
since they had swine flu and bird flu
and all that
so it's not really that crazy but um
yeah so
basically this is about an epidemic
that hits and starts like wiping out
people in
moscow and it sort of looks like it
makes the people look like
28 days later zombies a little bit like
it kind of turns their eyes white
and um i guess they don't like get ragey
or like run fast or nothing but it's
like they
they get real sick and it spreads really
quickly so
what ends up happening is that this um
pandemic starts spreading around
and then you're kind of focusing on
these two sort of interconnected
family neighbor kind of groups and their
struggle to get to
this cabin sort of that one of the guy's
dads has like tricked out i said at
least he used to be a boat and then it
got like
trapped in the middle of this lake
that's all iced over and he made it into
a cabin
so they think it's going to be safe out
there so the whole first season is like
their
journey like going to this place so
now i really liked this and like i'm
seeing like a lot of really good um
reviews of it but don't go into it
thinking
that it's gonna be like a zombie plague
or that there's gonna be like super gory
or anything it's basically like a drama
um about these people and about there's
enemies and stuff because there's like
this
these rogue groups going around that
like pretend that they're military but
then they're like wiping people out
so there's that and then there's like
you you know sick people you don't want
to get sick and everything like that
but it's mostly just kind of a drama
about them
with the epidemic kind of [ __ ] going on
like in the background
you know what i'm saying yeah i didn't
like it you didn't like it not really no
it was it was actually it had a good
potential
all right it's pretty good acting the
[ __ ]
the setting is really good because most
of it's happening in the snow
it's russian as [ __ ] you know what i
mean uh
but because it's not zombies the plague
victims really are not any kind of
threat well it's not threatening no you
you only see
you only see him a couple of times um
they don't seem to be any threat on the
[ __ ]
on the healthy population either so it's
so what you have is is you have a zombie
movies without any zombies and with no
threat of anything like zombies
you just have you end up with
a bunch of survivors um just um
killing each other kind of well yeah
it's more like and
honestly like a lot of zombie movies
have this too
that it's like you know it's not
necessarily the zombies you have to
worry about it's like other humans
because humans suck
but it's like this is like that but like
i said it happens in the pandemic just
because that's something that will like
wipe everyone out
um so it is like something that you have
to like like the infected people aren't
going to eat you or anything like that
but you do have to worry about getting
the disease
but i feel like that going on in the
background is just kind of like
makes everything chaos and then you have
like these dudes that are
like pretending to be military that are
going from town to town like wiping
people out
um so you have that as a threat and also
there's kind of like
these two um groups of people which are
traveling all together which is like a
guy
his new girlfriend his ex-wife who's
like super [ __ ]
um and his son from the first marriage
and then he's got like
um a son with asperger's that is his new
girlfriend's son and then he's got his
neighbor who's like
his one neighbor is like kind of a
douche and then he's got like a daughter
who's actually kind of awesome even
though she's like a drug addict and
she's kind of
had it has an attitude but like in a
cool way and uh he's got a like a really
young pregnant wife
and they all kind of like hate each
other so there's like a lot of
squabbling like not and
a lot a lot of vodka drinking holy crap
that's like the first thing
that they love is like this is russian
all right it's like the first thing they
do like they [ __ ] get to any new
place they're like where's the vodka did
anybody leave some [ __ ] vodka here
and so that's like the first thing
they're looking for like there's one
place they go like the the old guy boris
who was the main character's name is
sergey
and his dad boris they're kind of
estranged and boris is along too
and it's boris's cabin but it's like
they get to this one place and they
[ __ ] open this box and there's like
all this [ __ ] moonshine in there and
boris is like woohoo
score and they're like [ __ ] just
drinking the [ __ ] out of it that's
really really funny but like i said i
think that
you can't if you go into it thinking
that it's gonna be
like zombies then you'll be disappointed
because it's not zombies like i said
it's just an epidemic it's very
realistic there's nothing supernatural
about it or anything like that
and it's more like focused on um
the characters and the conflicts between
the characters and like you know what
this
like weird like you know fake military
group is up to and like you have to stay
away from them and like wondering if
they're gonna get there
also like the weather is like really
really bad and they have like all these
kind of you know shitty things happen
like with their cars
and like you know with nature being like
all
you know them being snowed in and stuff
like that so they have like all these
kind of struggles to overcome
so that said if you go into it with that
mindset
i actually think it was very good like
all the characters were really
interesting i really liked
um the interactions between them but
you know as i said if you just don't go
into it thinking it's a horror
series because it's not really it's kind
of like a drama that has like an
epidemic in the background
you know what i'm saying yeah i thought
it was kind of boring in a way
it didn't it doesn't even come close to
those first three or four seasons of uh
walking dead mega west if it's on
netflix yes it is yeah it's on netflix
it doesn't
i mean but here the interesting thing
was is like the very last episode of
that first season
they kind of teased you with a new
element coming in that might
happen like i said it's a it's a
cliffhanger for sure yeah but
that first season uh nah
no the the uh because because
just because the disease is not really a
threat if you ask me
right but i mean it's just yeah but like
i said that's kind of like not the main
that was just kind of like a thing
that's going on in the background that's
making everything suck
harder yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah but it's it's
it like i said it's a zombie movie it's
a zombie series
without the element of the zombies so
therefore
i don't know what it is i guess it's a
it's like a very toned down
zombie movie that's what it comes across
as and i just wouldn't have put the
[ __ ]
plague in it at all just have them die
instead of you know what i mean
they're zombie-like but why don't they
just go the whole way where there'd be a
bunch of them at once coming at you
because they've already made that like a
million yes i guess they just didn't
want to do that again
um fourth row down says nobody sleeps in
the woods tonight i've actually been
wanting to watch that so we'll prob
we'll probably uh get to watching that
so we can review it like
we can maybe we can do a matinee on that
on sunday or something like that because
i have been wanting to watch that
oh i did i actually watched something
really good i've been wanting to see
this movie for a long time you don't
watch it but um
it was i found it on hulu it came out in
2019 and i've been hearing like a lot of
buzz about it so i finally
like i saw it was on hulu and i was like
woo so i just like you know i got a
drink and sat down and watched it last
night
it's called wounds i don't know if you
guys have seen that movie but i
really really dug it it's like it's
pretty weird and
it ended sort of abruptly in the sense
that i didn't expect for it to end where
it did like i thought it was going to
keep going and then the credits rolled
and i was like
oh okay i didn't think that was going to
end there
but i really really liked this it was
like a really
weird like original story and i had no
[ __ ] idea where it was going which
was good like because i'm sitting there
going what the [ __ ]
is going on with this [ __ ] and it also
has that chick that was in all the
50 shades of grey movies but don't like
hold that against her because she's
actually good in this movie
i haven't seen the 50 shades of grey
movies but i heard they were terrible
the books are terrible
that's for sure but uh yeah so i heard
the movies were bad too
but uh yeah so anything else you would
like to add on to the
[ __ ] about the series or whatever i
don't really have much comments about it
yeah i mean like that was just mediocre
kind of you know i i liked it like i
said but it's a character drama
it's not i thought it was a high budget
missed opportunity
could have been excellent but it wasn't
mediocre
david defranco says uh nathan ballinger
i hope i'm pronouncing that right wrote
the story based on wounds his short
story collection north american lake
monsters
i've heard of that collection and i've
actually been wanting to watch that
because i thought it was like based on a
story or a book or something so you know
and like i said i'd been
hearing so much about that movie and i
was like really excited that uh hulu had
it because netflix doesn't and shutter
doesn't
so i'm really glad i finally got to see
it because it was weird as [ __ ] and woo
if you are like afraid of cockroaches
wow there's a lot of cockroaches in this
movie and like i was like watching it
going i did not expect there'd be so
many cockroaches that i was getting like
really stressed out about it because
cockroaches like [ __ ] gross me out
but yeah um i think this series to the
lake was based on a book as well but i
can't remember the name of the author
um but yeah so what's it's wednesday so
uh
tomorrow is witching hour friday is the
movie retrospective and then we'll be
back to do another live stream on
saturday evening as usual
doing a uh episode gonna go more in a
paranormal direction this time if you're
one of our patrons you already know
what the topic's gonna be because you
all voted on it and uh it won pretty
handily
so uh hopefully you guys will enjoy that
and we will talk to you again on
saturday
thanks for stopping by bye